there's one player who i would say is
the exception to all of this
um and he's one of my favorite people to
talk about in terms of
i think he might have cracked the
simulation uh it's phil hellmuth
uh he
in more ways than one he's a practice
simulation i think yeah he
somehow to this day is still and i love
you phil don't i'm not in any way
knocking you um
he's still winning
so much at the world series of poker
specifically um he's now on 16 bracelets
the next serious person i think is 110
um
and he is consistently year in year out
going deep or winning these huge field
tournaments you know with like 2 000
people um which statistically he should
not be doing
and
and yet
you watch some of the plays he makes and
they make no sense like mathematically
they are so far from game theory optimal
yeah and the thing is if you went and
stuck him in one of these like
high-stakes cash games with a bunch of
like gto people he's going to get ripped
apart but there's something that he has
that when he's in the halls of the world
series of poker specifically
um
amongst sort of amateurish players
he gets them to do crazy [ __ ] like that
and and
but my little pet theory is that also
he
just the car he's he's like a wizard and
he gets the cards to do what he needs
them to do
because he
ex he just expects to win and he expects
to rece you know to get flopper set with
a frequency far beyond what this you
know the the the real percentages are
and i don't even know if he knows what
the real percentages are he doesn't need
to because he gets there i think he has
found the chico because when i've seen
him play he seems to be like annoyed
that the long shot thing didn't happen
yes
he's like annoyed and it's almost like
everybody else is stupid because he was
obviously going to win with this
if that silly thing hadn't happened and
it's like you don't understand the silly
thing happens 99 percent of the time and
it's a one percent not the other way
around but genuinely for his lived
experience at the world only at the
monster as a poker it is like that so i
don't blame him for feeling that way um
but he does he has this he has this x
factor and
the poker community has tried for years
to rip him down saying like you know he
doesn't he's no good but he's clearly
good because he's still winning or
there's something going on whether
that's he's figured out how to
mess with the fabric of reality and how
cards or you know a randomly shuffled
deck of cards come out i don't know what
it is but he's doing doing it right
still
you